dragon closing in we're inside 20 meters
after the noise and speed of yesterday's
launch the SpaceX capsules serenely inch
towards its final destination dragon on
the big loop or in fact and then the
International Space Station almost
Within Reach
soft capture complete this complex
process entirely automated the two-man
NASA team of Doug Hurley and Bob Behnken
just had to sit and wait so I can
capture complete standby for docking
completion dragon SpaceX docking
sequence is complete and with that
history was made for the second time in
24 hours after becoming the first
privately owned craft to launch humans
into orbit it's now the first to dock
here all the previous visitors have
arrived on government built rockets but
now billionaire Elon Musk's company
joins that elite club and with that the
hatch is open American Chris Cassidy
opened the hatch to welcome his fellow
countrymen aboard we have Bob Behnken
from SpaceX demo two mission entering
the International Space Station they
joined him in the two Russian residents
of the ISS for a planned for month stay
followed by got Hurley social distancing
clearly not a consideration 260 miles
above the surface of the earth it's
great to get the United States back in
the crude launch business and we're just
really glad to be on board this
magnificent complex we do hope to put
her through our paces and so the good
ship endeavour is going to get a lot of
a check out over the next week or two
here and hopefully we'll be able to
declare her operational politicians were
on hand at Mission Control to
congratulate them this test flight
hasn't been without problems the
original launch was delayed scuppered by
bad weather it almost happened again on
Saturday but the clouds cleared right on
cue at Florida's Kennedy Space Center
allowing the rocket a clear path and
heralding a new era in space travel
where businesses not government's
stumped up much of the cost President
Trump insists it'll free up NASA to
focus on the next chapter returning
humans to the moon with the next stop
Mars Kip Rachel
Sky News